this one's from a couple weeks ago we
played this one for you he had Vivek
Rama Swami on and Chuck's a little
confused about how many genders there
are so Vivek did a nice job using
trademark science
how do you know it's that again how do
you know are you confident that you know
that gender uh is uh as binary as you're
describing it are you confident that it
isn't a spectrum I am you know this as a
scientist well there's there's two X
chromosomes if you're a woman an X and A
Y that means a lot of scientific
research out there there's a lot of
scientific research out there that says
gender is a spectrum Chuck I
respectfully disagree gender dysphoria
for most of our history all the way
through the DSM-5 has been characterized
as a mental health disorder and I don't
think it's compassionate to affirm that
I think that's cruelty when a kid is
crying out for help what they're asking
for is you gotta ask the question of
what else is going wrong at home what
else is going wrong at school let's be
compassionate and get to the heart of
that rather than playing this game as
though we're actually changing our
medical understanding for the last time
yeah that's good work by bevec and uh
I'm in a little Twitter spat with vivec
at the moment which we're going to get
to in a moment but as you know I like
giving the devil is due and when you do
good work and you confront these guys
and call them out on their nonsense
Chuck Todd knows there's a man and
there's a woman and then if you want to
be a man who dresses like a woman and
acts like a woman and names uh yourself
a female name as an adult blah blah blah
blah blah almost everybody is on board
you live in your life as you see fit but
that was a nice job of just clean clear
explanation by vivec foreign
[Music]